here's a video from a popular polyamory
Tik Tok account called remodeled love
what I was just saying is that this man
gets it okay because you are a catch and
he makes an effort he puts
intentionality into his communication he
comments on your posts and your stuff he
makes plans he wants to be around he's
proactive he's got a great attitude just
in general and he's just a delight to be
around you may be asking yourself are
any of these people actually happy
living this way no I'm because again if
you're a normal person and you see all
this and you hear all this you think
well that just sounds totally miserable
like that sounds it's like a walking
nightmare the guy in that video we just
played a moment ago is trying his best
to appear happy and quote unquote
supportive but if you listen to these
people speak for longer than 20 seconds
you'll find that their their deep
profound unhappiness eventually comes
seeping through and soon it's the only
thing you can see when you look at them